i always want to get better i want to be  the best basketball player i could  possibly be  i use my imagination a lot i just let  the rhythm of the game take me wherever  i need to go  okay colby doing work 2-4 on my shirt  he's the greatest on the court and i'm  the greatest on the verse  going for this fourth ring like it was  his first gotta get the gleam  do it for karine so nice my  flow's so mean catch me at the game  sitting next to goldstein  [Music]  rap monster cross over good or turn  around  jumper or just drive the lane and dunk  on donkeys  you know where it's going it's going  down yo this is the late show  but don't drown though i call him king  bryant  now let the crown show